.
OKAY COME HERE WITH REACTION,
CALIFORNIA GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE LARRY ELDER.
I'VE ALWAYS DOUBTED, I'VE HAD
THIS DOUBT THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD
GET TO QUESTION TWO.
IF YOU GET A QUESTION TWO RIGHT
NOW YOU HAVE A SIGNIFICANT LEAD
IN THE POLLS.
MY QUESTION IS THIS, THESE POLLS
HOLD AND IF SO, WHY?
>> WELL, SEAN, THERE'S A REASON
THAT 45,000 PEOPLE HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO MY CANDIDACY.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE ACTUAL
FUND-RAISING NUMBERS LATER ON
PUT OUT BUT 2.2 MILLION PEOPLE
SIGNED A PETITION TO HAVE THIS
MAN RECALLED.
TALKING ABOUT 25% OF THEM, AT
LEAST INDEPENDENTS AND DEMOCRATS
WHO JUST VOTED FOR HIM TWO YEARS
EARLIER, SO IT'S AWFULLY HARD TO
CHARACTERIZE THIS AS A
REPUBLICAN TAKEOVER.
AND 53% OF PEOPLE SAY THEY DON'T
WANT GAVIN NEWSOM TO HAVE A
SECOND TERM.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE CRIME,
BECAUSE OF THE RISING
HOMELESSNESS, BECAUSE OF THE
OUTRAGEOUS WAY HE HAS SHUT DOWN
THE STATE IN THE MOST RICARDIAN
WAY THAN ANY OTHER 50 STATES
WHILE SITTING UP THERE AT FRENCH
LAUNDRY RESTAURANT WITH THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT DRAFTED THE
MANDATES, NOT WEARING MASKS,
TELLING EVERYONE ELSE TO DO JUST
THAT.
THEN THE OUTRAGEOUS COST OF
LIVING BECAUSE OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EXTREMISTS, HE
DOESN'T WANT TO STAND DOWN,
COSTS 150% MORE THAN THE AVERAGE
PRICE OF A HOME IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU ADD IT ALL UP, THIS GUY'S
GOT TO GO AND AS YOU POINT OUT,
MORE PEOPLE WANT HIM TO GO THEN
WANT HIM TO STAY.
HE'S VERY, VERY NERVOUS.
>> Sean: HE CERTAINLY IS.
I GUESS WHILE PUTTING DRACONIAN
RESTRICTIONS ON THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA, NO IN SCHOOL
LEARNING, BUT HIS KIDS HAD IN
SCHOOL LEARNING IN A PRIVATE
SCHOOL, OR PICTURES OF HIS KIDS
AT A SUMMER CAMP WHILE EVERYBODY
ELSE HAD TO MASK UP, THEY HAD NO
MASKS, APPARENTLY.
I THINK ONE TOO MANY EXAMPLES OF
JUST UNDER ELITE AND HYPOCRISY.
SPEAKING OF CUOMO, LET ME RUN
"THE NEW YORK POST" IMAGES.
I DON'T KNOW, LARRY, WHAT DO I
KNOW?
I'M JUST A TALK SHOW HOST ABOUT
11 WOMEN MAKING SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST YOU THAT A
REPORT FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN NEW YORK SAYS HE IS CRIMINAL
BOTH ON THE STATE LEVEL AND A
FEDERAL LEVEL AND THERE HE IS
TODAY POOLSIDE WITH A YOUNG AIDE
AND THERE THEY ARE TOGETHER.
I DON'T THINK THE OPTICS ARE
EXACTLY IDEAL.
>> NOW, THEY AREN'T AND THE
OPTICS IN CALIFORNIA WEREN'T
IDEAL WHEN HE HAD, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, GAVIN NEWSOM, HIS
OWN KIDS IN SUMMER CAMP NOT
WEARING MASKS WHILE JUST
MOMENTARILY HE HAD SUGGESTED
THAT EVERYBODY ELSE SHOULD BE
WEARING MASKS.
YOU MENTIONED EDUCATION.
75% OF BLACK BOYS IN CALIFORNIA,
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP, CANNOT
READ AT STATE LEVELS OF
PROFICIENCY AND THAT WAS
PREPANDEMIC AND THE LEVELS OF
PROFICIENCY ARE VERY HIGH.
NEARLY HALF OF ALL THIRD-GRADERS
CANNOT AND I LOST A WHOLE YEAR
OF IN-SCHOOL EDUCATION WHILE AS
YOU POINTED OUT, HIS OWN KIDS
WERE ENJOYING IN PERSON PRIVATE
EDUCATION.
IT'S WHY ONE OF THE MANY THINGS
I'M GOING TO DO IF I'M FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE LIKE THE GOVERNORS
TO PUSH FOR CHOICE.
THE MONEY SHOULD FOLLOW THE
CHILD, RATHER THAN THE OTHER WAY
AROUND.
THE POLLS SHOW THAT BLACK AND
BROWN PARENTS OVERWHELMINGLY
WANT SCHOOL CHOICE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOT
GIVING IT TO THEM.
I WANT TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
AND THAT IS WHY I'M ASKING
PEOPLE TO THROW A LITTLE
SOMETHING IN THE TIP JAR.
HE CAN RAISE AN UNLIMITED AMOUNT
OF MONEY,